so hello everybody i am very excited to
be here with bishop barron most of you
will not need uh an introduction to him
he is the catholic bishop of california
he is also the right of many books he
runs word on fire which has many
publishing recently a publishing on
jordan peterson and i've been with him
with jordan peterson on his channel
recently with john viveki to talk about
christianity its place in the modern
world so we thought it would be a good
idea to continue the conversation just
both of us to talk about the bible about
beauty about art and about how
christianity can exist in uh in the
contemporary culture
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
so bishop baron thank you for coming
here
jonathan thank you good to see you and
good to be on with you thanks for the
invitation oh it's it's wonderful uh i
wanted to maybe we can start off and
maybe after the fact after our
discussion what was your impression with
jordan and with john of how that went
and and what what kind of place this
type of discussion could have in the in
the present state
yeah i love the conversation i thought
it was really interesting and you know
different perspectives you and i
explicitly uh christian
uh john vervicky i don't really know his
background that well i know he's
cognitive scientist professor at
university of toronto i found his
musings on kind of western intellectual
history really interesting um and of
course jordan peterson
uh
you know someone that's i think deeply
interested in spiritual matters not
explicitly a christian but very
interested in it so it was just
throwing light from different angles on
this thing which i thought was
intriguing but we all come together
in being concerned about meaning or
better the lack thereof in our culture
and the crisis it's it's causing in
young people especially i mean i see it
every day in my pastoral work and the
work on on the internet so i loved that
i think that was really fruitful thing
for us all to be talking about
i think one of the interesting things
that seems to be happening and jordan
does
also seem to be someone who opened the
this door or kind of participated in
opening the door you'd participate in
this as well which is
we had this kind of last new atheist
moment you know with sam harris and
dawkins and all of these people
and uh it seems like that moment has
broken it's broken and there's something
about the zeitgeist which makes it
possible for
i'm seeing it a lot of atheists who
perceive
even what it is we're talking about
because this has been difficult for me
until
maybe five six years ago is that when we
talk about the stories we talk about the
bible and how it's it's a world view
rather than something that you kind of
analyze from above we can enter into
these stories and participate it's
something which until recently i felt
like people weren't even able to to
grasp but now that door has been opened
you know there's a lot there i remember
a teacher mine saying years ago that
sometimes a block in the spiritual life
can simply be an intellectual conundrum
or it's a question or it's something i'm
just stuck and until i get unstuck i
can't move any deeper into the spiritual
truth and i think for a lot of young
people
and the new atheists spoke to this there
were intellectual blocks
you know isn't christianity just a
pre-modern nonsense it's opposed to
science it's a bunch of old superstition
it's a projection of our of our
idealized self-understanding you know
all the usual things and young people
got stuck they probably heard a lot of
that in their college and university uh
classrooms they thought yeah okay
religion is just a lot of nonsense the
new atheists
they geared all that up again you know
well here's the thing
in a way that does great service because
it allows us to deal with some of these
problems that young people have and
thereby to eliminate false
understandings of religion
i like the cleansing quality of of
atheists from
goldman foyerbach all the way to to sam
harris they they do something they they
cleanse
idolatrous understandings of religion
they um they raise and therefore allow
us to address some of the intellectual
blocks
once that's over
then
as you say i think quite rightly people
can begin to move into the spiritual
power of these great texts and these
great symbols and these great doctrines
but in a way i'm i'm happy that the new
atheists
led to a renaissance in uh christian
apologetics in christian philosophy
uh we we had to pick up our game because
to tell you the truth we were god-awful
when the new atheists came by we i mean
the whole christian
world we didn't we didn't know how to
address them which was stupid because we
have extraordinary resources in our
intellectual tradition but but you know
that's a long story we threw down our
arms to a large extent because we were
so concerned about dialoguing with the
culture and reaching out to the culture
we we lost our edge apologetically but
that's dangerous because when the
atheist critique comes and it always
comes in some form we got to be able to
meet it or young people especially will
get stuck and then they won't be able to
move into the wider world i think as i
read jordan peterson there's something
i've always found kind of this lovely
innocence about him like he just
discovers certain things and then begins
to talk about them and what he
discovered was
the spiritual power of the bible
and we again i'm speaking broadly we
christians we were kind of lousy at that
too we weren't very good at opening up
our own spiritual riches
and so peterson
he said hey look hey look young people
look at all this stuff
and they responded like crazy to it
which doesn't surprise me at all
so that's how i read the moment um the
new atheist critique was cleansing in a
way and
peterson has been like as i was kidding
saying like a gateway drug for many
people into the real spiritual stuff and
so you know thank god for him yeah that
and one of the surprising things to me
has been to even realize that
post-modernism with all its with all its
damage that it's done it's actually
opened an interesting door as well which
is
that
and we can see it actually as we watch
the breakdown of our social narrative
and we see as we see it fragment all of
a sudden even the most materialist
person has to pay attention to story has
to pay attention to the fact that we're
actually living inside competing stories
and so
once that becomes clear even sadly in
terms of politics then you can also use
that to help people say well
that's exactly these stories in
scripture are more like a story that you
live in then a description of
of kind of facts in the way that uh
chemists will describe facts or you know
a physicist will describe facts and it
opens up the door to say yeah we have to
wait before i analyze the world i have
to string string a bunch of facts
together in a narrative in order to be
able to even make my way through the
world
yeah
you know post-modernism does have a
nihilistic side to it or like a purely
kind of deconstructive side but there's
the aspect i like to call the nostalgic
post-modernism that looks behind what
the enlightenment occluded so modernity
or the enlightenment with all its
rationalism and scientism
tended to occlude great parts of our
tradition and we talked about that with
with jordan a few weeks ago is this
whole wisdom tradition got occluded many
ways by the hyper rationalism of the
enlightenment so one side of
post-modernism is to kind of break that
up is to break through that occluding
wall so that we can again revisit these
sources so in that way it's been
liberating post-modernism i wrote a book
a couple years ago called the priority
of christ toward a post-liberal
catholicism
and that's what i meant was
post-liberal beyond the the
enlightenment
tinged reading of christianity which i
would have gotten as a young guy that
was very much in vogue after vatican ii
was a very enlightenment reading of
christianity well i think we have to
break through that but as a break back
to something that had been occluded and
i that's what peterson's doing in my
judgment standing up in front of people
and he's giving a patriotistic reading
of the of the bible in many ways he's
doing what i think what the father's
called the tropological sense or the the
moral sense of the bible he'd probably
say peterson probably say the
psychological meaning yeah but okay the
the i call it the moral meaning of the
bible
great great he's doing that he's finding
a tradition going back to origin of
alexandria you know going back to philo
he's recovering a very ancient tradition
that was very much occluded by
the hyper-rationalistic approach to the
bible i don't know about your own
training but certainly mine was almost
exclusively
in historical criticism which means
you know in a very rationalistic way we
look at the biblical texts as ancient
near eastern literature we try to
understand the what the author's
intention was what his environing
culture looked like what were his
concerns in like late 8th century bc
judea et cetera
well i mean fine
oh that's fine
but what it didn't allow
is what peterson is exploring and what
the church fathers explored what does
this text tell me about god and my
relationship to god and my relationship
to the deepest meaning of my life a lot
of that got set aside by a very
rationalistic enlightenment tinged
approach to the bible
what i hear you doing what i hear
peterson doing is opening up older
wisdom sources
yeah definitely i i think that's true
from myself it's very strange because i
mean i studied art
and then i studied theology after but i
came to theology
let's say from an iconological
perspective that is that i was
interested in the way in which images
spoke to each other
and created these patterns of meaning
and so for me you know when i would get
i took some theology classes in colleges
even before i i studied more
more intense intensely and i just
remember being
annoyed right away just annoyed because
i was like what is this what are where
are the stories where where are the
images um and it really is through the
psychological approach that i discovered
typology and then when i read san gregor
vanessa i read stand up from the syrian
i was like this is home right right and
then i started to see
that how the new testament is just
basically quoting the old testament
constantly and referring back to all
these images and so it it took right
created a like a like a token
world building you could say you know
like that that there's this world
building in scripture that you can
inhabit and that it's a series of
analogies and a series of references
that you can live in and uh so i was
never too i was always annoyed with the
with the critical historical from the
beginning there's so much there can i
ask you something right away it just
came to my mind go all the way back to
what 7th century 8th century the
iconoclast controversy in john of
damascus right this i think pivotal
moment in the history of christianity
when you've got
a somewhat puritanical you know against
graven imagery somewhat islamic
influenced view that would say you don't
do this you know but then john of
damascus who said no because god made an
icon of himself the icon of the
invisible god is the humanity of jesus
and so that becomes the ground for
iconography and for christian art you
know i've argued no john of damascus no
sistine chapel no shark cathedral i mean
in a way the whole visual tradition
comes from this incarnational
sensibility so there's that that old old
old battle against the iconoclasts but
then come up to the 16th century and a
big part of the reformation was an
iconoclastic instinct you know you go to
churches in europe and you can see it
you can see these places that were that
were wrecked i mean literally windows
broken and statues
knocked down
well i'll tell you a third example of it
is in my own lifetime
look at the churches built
catholic churches built in like the 60s
70s 80s when i was coming of age bon
valtezar one of my favorite theologians
called them the great barns of the
reformation and what he meant was it was
a new iconoclasm it was denuding these
buildings of
symbolism imagery
color
the great big brick empty kind of
bauhaus modernist buildings
well you know i went to europe to study
to get my doctorate i went to paris
and um
chart and notre dame and the san
chapelle and the hulong cathedral and
and france
and
here's this poor kid growing up in 1970s
america where church buildings were
meant to be oh no stark brick
no no get rid of the pictures get rid of
it it's a it was it was a very
rationalistic way to build church
buildings but then you go to europe and
these buildings are just they're
crawling with symbolism and iconography
and color and narrativity and so on uh
and i remember realizing very
consciously
i'm a what 29 year old guy i'm in paris
thinking
man something went wrong
something went wrong with the cr with
the catholic spirit so
that's a long-ranting speech about from
the iconoclast controversy up to the
reformation to my own time there are
these outbreaks of iconoclasm
that are rationalistic anti-imagistic
anti-narrative anti-symbolic and that
wreaks havoc because the soul feeds you
know that and the soul feeds on all that
stuff that's what what nourishes us
you peterson others i think are saying
hey hey look at this world that's on the
far side of an iconoclasm yeah they
yeah i'm in quebec right and so quebec
used to be the
place in the world and so
you can see it you can because we have
so many churches and so you can you can
see the decline and how in the 50s and
60s it was starting and then it
accelerated to these monstrous
things these monstrous just horrible
buildings that so you agree with me
no one cares about no one likes them
everybody hates them and and there's
something even more even not just the
images but the actual transformation of
the space from a traditional
hierarchical space yeah right this
desire to eliminate this three-part
structure of the church which is the
same as the temple the temple right one
of the oldest structures in you know
it's just all even pagan temples are
made this way you know the sense of
entering into the mystery and flattening
everything so the flattening of the
symbolism ended up being the same
flattening of culture that happened all
around we democratized it and i mean
that is a very strong criticism you know
that i remember the years when the
priest and see
here's the mistake people made
oh the priest you think bob barron is
this such an important guy that he
belongs up in that chair in front of
everybody come on it's not bob barron
it's it's the priest who's has this
symbolic role acting in persona christi
uh
it's christ presiding at the liturgy you
know and and the priest garbed so as to
mask his own kind of grubby identity
it's not
robert baron it's this symbolic figure
now in persona christie and then we did
it across the board with the
architecture with the liturgy with our
style we flattened it democratized it
and we robbed it of all that that
evocative business do you know the book
eve kongar one of the great
pre-conciliar theologians wrote a book
called the mystery trump the mystery of
the temple and it was it's now it's like
it was a seed that was planted long time
ago but it's come up all the catholic
theologians now are reading that book
they're rereading it to say yes
the temple
and as you know i mean the temple
hearkens back to the garden i mean it's
this great symbol from the very
beginning but when we denude the temple
of all of its cosmic
and psychological and spiritual
symbolism then it becomes as indeed many
thought it should become just a
gathering space you know i remember
hearing that as a young guy oh no the
church is just you know it's where the
it's the pilgrim people on the way and
we put the tent up for a while and we
stay there well that's turning the
temple back into the tabernacle from the
book of exodus the temple is meant to be
um it's the access mundi right i mean
it's the place where we connect to the
deepest value
and christian the christian temple is
also eschatological the the structure of
the church is based i always tell even i
remember when protestants would tell me
that why are we going back to this old
testament stuff well it's actually
mostly based on revelation because
the altar in the temple was not in the
holy of holies the altar was in the
court and the reason why the altar is in
the holy of holies is because of the
cross and it's because of what we
division in revelation of the lamb on
the altar as the as the kind of fulcrum
of of the worship and so
we're actually it's and you can see it
in early roman churches you you've seen
these these early roman churches that
the entire decoration of the church is
eschatological it's all the 24 elders
and you know the singing angels and the
new jerusalem this is the imagery that
actually
propuls iconography was this first this
emit this church as a as a place where
the the let's say
the return of christ is already
happening we're already participating in
the kingdom it had this kind of glorious
aspect to it you're absolutely right but
can i say this i
i'd be willing to bet if you talk to
95 of catholics they wouldn't understand
that because they we weren't taught that
uh
gathering place
where we come together as a community
around the table of the lord we heard
all that language and again may i say
and you know i'm i'm a great reader and
admirer of many protestant theologians
and so on but it's a totally
protestantized understanding of of the
church and the liturgy it's where the
people out of their free will decide to
gather as a community around the table
of the lord with no decoration only the
word being proclaimed etc
but what you're talking about which is
classic stuff it's deeply rooted in the
bible comes roaring up into the great
tradition but trust me when i tell you
within catholicism a lot of that was
forgotten about and it wasn't taught
that when you step into the church
you're stepping into
an icon of heaven
and that the uh
language of may our voices join with the
voices of the angels i don't if most
catholics if they even hear that
language would say oh it's nice little
pious decoration
no that we we mean it
the the heavenly worship is is being
participated in and represented
iconically by our worship here below
no that's i'd say most catholics would
miss all that yeah there are some people
right now in the church that are really
trying to revive that tradition
yeah and i think balthazar you mentioned
him before
yeah really
poked at this and was able to kind of
awaken some some little flame i think
for myself in the orthodox tradition
there's a lot that has been preserved a
lot more of that kind of cosmic uh
vision i think it was also
in the 19th 20th century you can feel it
slipping away but it seems like because
it had been kept for so long that there
was enough to revive it today and i'm
pretty happy i'm pretty excited that the
things that i'm presenting
um
some people are surprised by what i'm
presenting and then a lot of my
hierarchy has been recognizing it and
saying no this is this is actually you
know this is what san gregory says
saying this is what assainefram is
saying i'm just presenting it maybe a
little differently for the modern people
to understand well tell me i don't know
the answer to this tell me would most
people in let's say the various orthodox
traditions would they understand their
own liturgical
richness or or have they suffered too
from some of this rationalization and
flattening out
i think i think individually i think
that's happened you know definitely you
can see it
on the verge of communism and on the
verge of all the chaos of the 20th
century you can feel the meaning
slipping you know and it slips in
different directions it doesn't just
slip towards materialism it also slips
towards the kind of weird esotericism
you see that in the russian church
especially all these strange icons start
to appear um
but i i feel like today there is enough
there and the emphasis on say maximus
which has been happening since the 50s
you know with balthazar he's a goose
catholic but this emphasis on maximus
has been a lifesaver and has helped
people come back towards this this
cosmic vision of the liturgy and but and
around me i
when i talk to people everybody is
people maybe don't necessarily
understand the specifics of it but they
at least understand the basic notion of
it and
and aren't of scared by they don't find
it pagan or strange the way that
peop in our tradition was ratzinger um
you know who's on other
joseph rossigno in his texts on liturgy
and he's grounded in people like
guardini going further back in the 20th
century but the cosmic dimension
ratzinger felt had really been forgotten
and i can i can testify as someone that
was that came of age during that time
absolutely no one thought of the liturgy
cosmically we thought of it as the place
where the community gathers for mutual
support and to
revive our interest in kind of making
the world a better place yeah i would
say that's how we understood it and that
we were strengthened at the table of the
lord to do the work of building the
kingdom now again there's place for all
that language there is place for it but
the as you say the eschatological the
cosmic the transcendental all of that
was under-emphasized and ratzinger
was trying to recover it
then he becomes pope and that's why he
put such a stress on the liturgy but
recovering in a fresh way
now as you know their liturgy war is
going on all the time and they've been
revived in the catholic church over the
latin
you know versus vernacular issue but see
the deeper thing rotsinger wasn't say
boy oh boy let's go back to latin he was
saying boy oh boy let's go back to
exactly what you're talking about let's
go back if you want to this cosmic and
richly
symbolic eschatological understanding of
liturgy and i think that's still very
much what we need to do definitely but
it's tough because you can see how
ratzinger was attacked
yeah yeah even for trying to be
connected back to
you know their own tradition you know
taking out an old cross and bringing it
out in procession all of a sudden
everybody's saying look at the ridge
vatican
that's a museum piece what are you gonna
do you're gonna dismantle it and sell it
it's been in the church for you know 400
years or 500 years and so there's there
he was just constantly attacked for his
vestments for for the the processions
for the the the desire to kind of bring
back this this vision of the kingdom
let's say in terms of in terms of the
material use of it and so it's difficult
because there is also
uh there is also a fight there is like
you said there's a liturgy war there are
people who see that as as a kind of
ostentation or as just a yeah
but do you agree with this uh i mean
that goes right back to the apostles and
judas you know i mean couldn't this have
been sold in the money exactly
and then jesus though with this
wonderfully extravagant sense of you
know what she's done and and and he
explains what she's done in this
beautiful i mean ultimately cosmic sort
of perspective about his death and his
resurrection and so on um but see that
attitude
which i would
i'd bring it from judas if you
all the way to immanuel kant
18th century would say well religion is
fundamentally about ethics right so
liturgy and sacraments and prayer and
all that stuff is kind of extraneous
what really matters about religion is
ethics well see i think we're all
conscience now in a way
how often people today would say
something like oh you know it doesn't
really matter what you believe as long
as you're a good person
or
you know you're a social justice warrior
for all the right causes that's what
matters and all the other stuff is kind
of fufu or if it helps you god bless you
but the really important thing is that
you're ethically committed well that's
right out of the kant playbook that's
right out of couldn't this have been
sold given to the poor
where in fact religion is
that indeed as an implication there's
ethical implications and and social
implications of course but it's grounded
in something much
stranger and weirder and wonderful and
sacramental and eschatological
but that all got bracketed i think in
the kantian manner as extraneous to the
ethical core
that's done a lot of damage yeah but you
talked to most catholics i think would
probably subscribe they don't know it's
kant but to a kantian view as long as
i'm a good person that's all that
matters but as you say like bringing a
gorgeous cross out of the vatican
museum someplace
well it's it's not just boy how much is
that worth and we give it to the poor
it's
it's splendid
and it it opens a a window in the soul
and you know it accomplishes all these
things that go beyond the merely ethical
yeah exactly i mean nobody
it's funny because nobody complained
when you know they build these monstrous
uh buildings like the like the
guggenheim uh bilbao or whatever this
massive huge nobody complaining when you
build this massive multi-million dollar
uh temple to modern to modern thinking
but if it's if it's to be if it's given
to god then no it all has to go to the
poor the image of judas you use i've
used this several times to kind of talk
about
hierarchy right that it begins with
worship and this is something which is
people are now starting to understand
almost technically that
the first thing that's important is what
you're focusing on it's the right the
talos or the the reason is is there
before all the rest and so when christ
says the first you give up to god and
then you care for the poor those are not
opposites right they don't contradict
each other actually one leads to the
other because if you just create a kind
of social justice mesh this kind of
social justice thing it becomes totally
open to corruption
if you don't have the highest ideal
first then the other thing becomes a
system and i've seen it i worked in in
africa and kind of charity work for
several years and some of it was just
monstrous and just because you give
money doesn't mean that it does what you
think it does if it's not orient if all
your attention isn't oriented to
something which is actually judging you
people hate to hear that but judging you
in the sense that it's the ultimate good
to which you're looking then the rest
will fall apart at some point well
that's why i i learned this from the
church fathers both east and west
if there is a master theme of the entire
bible
and it's always dangerous to say but if
there's a great master theme in the
entire bible i would say it's orthodoxy
by which i simply mean right worship
write praise so we're made
to lead all of creation in a chorus of
praise to the true god that's how the
fathers tended to read the genesis
account
i interpret it in a sort of catholic way
as this stately liturgical procession
of all the things coming forth from god
you know one after the other in a
beautiful ordered harmonic procession at
the end of which comes
the leader of the praise that's the
person the bishop or priest that comes
at the end of the procession is now to
lead the praise so now we know what
human beings are for they're for right
praise and not just for themselves but
on behalf of all creation and there as
you say eden itself is a temple
an elevated place because the rivers run
out from it so it's an elevated place
and human beings are meant there to be
priests kings as well and all that but
priests
leading creation in the course of praise
so what goes wrong bad praise it's
always the problem of the bible i don't
know an exception really yeah whether
you're looking in exodus or the first
book of kings or anywhere you're looking
the problem is bad praise and from bad
praise follows everything else bad the
disintegration of the self
and that's what you know i think
peterson and company are really good the
psychologists they can talk about that
what it's like when that when i
disintegrate on the inside
and that comes from bad praise i start
praising money or fame or power or
whatever you know i'm like the priest of
bao i'm hopping around the wrong altar
and i'm slashing
they they're bleeding well that's that's
people today i think that's people in
addictive patterns today hopping around
the altars of baal and they're and
they're harming themselves
so elijah does what the biblical figures
always do
which is he calls it back to right
praise you know and that's the only way
that the fire is going to fall if we're
properly aligned to god
so i i think that's the whole story of
the bible in many ways then jesus how do
we read him but the new adam he's the
new david he's the new temple he's the
he's the one
divinity humanity come together in him
he's the point of right praise he's
humanity giving right praise to god you
know so
if anything i put my finger on that as
the master motif of the bible and see
here it's what we need to tell the world
i'll speak as a catholic we lost
confidence in ourselves
our game became so much let's make
ourselves pleasing to the culture
you know when i was a young guy it's
reaching out to the culture making sure
the culture
understands and let's use the culture's
language we lost confidence in ourselves
and honestly the culture wasn't that
interested in us you know what i'm
saying they weren't reaching back to us
with enormo they were like oh yeah great
as we move on where the church ought to
say no in season and out no matter where
the stupid culture is
we proclaim christ and we proclaim right
praise which brings us back into right
order and so on and in the meantime this
you know culture that we're all trying
to to uh to mollify it's the priest of
baal and there there are 450 of them
right i mean they always outnumber us
there's one in elijah but by god he was
the right prophet but there are 450
priests about they're all over the place
in the culture why why are we
pandering to that culture as our primary
move we should be declaring the way
elijah did
anyway end of rant i mean that's a
harmony no but you're you're very right
and i think that
i i think i think that even just 10
years ago
saying that would have just gone over
people's heads people would not have
understood why worship is important and
i think so we in a way we can absolve
some of our
the people before us because
there's something that happened this
kind of materialism this kind of
physicalism which made people forget
that the world is primarily made by
through attention that is
from the very
beginning of genesis when god declares
and sees and judges as good you realize
that this is actually how the world
comes together and the things to which
you attend will
flow downstream and will
create fruits and so if you worship
money if you worship other things and
that the pattern of addiction
is a liturgical pattern yeah it's just a
satanic liturgy and anybody who's gone
through
addictions will notice that because it
has an order and you and it always
happens the same way it's like you fall
in these sins and you just keep
repeating them over and over and the
same person can find it stupid that that
a christian will repeat his daily
prayers every day but then they'll still
reach for that cigarette and not realize
that that they're doing the same thing
but their pattern is destroying them and
eating them up and enslaving them rather
than bringing them higher towards higher
patterns no absolutely um the way it
works i and i read this in the in the
father's but also in more contemporary
people
because i mean what the fathers would
have called an aquinas maybe
concupiscence we might translate today
as addiction because you start
worshiping something other than god
well you get a buzz from it because
you're you're in a impassioned way
around some worldly good and it really
is a worldly good whether it's pleasure
it's honor it's power whatever
so okay i get a buzz from that but the
buzz will have to wear off because we're
not meant for that the hearts wrestles
to rest in god and so
it wears off all right i better go back
to that source again
and so i strive and strive this drive or
i hop around the altar again and again
and again and then i get it so it's more
wealth and more honor more power and i
get a buzz
but every addict knows that it's less
this intense the second time so now i
start to really panic and i go back now
with a with a kind of insistence and i'm
hopping like mad around that altar now
now i'm drawing blood now i'm wounding
myself because i'm so addicted and then
before you know it you are in this
little awful cycle and it's the same you
the woman at the well is the same thing
you know you come to this well every day
and you drink but you still get thirsty
i want to give you water welling up in
you to eternal life i want to break you
from that addictive pattern because i
want to hook you on to the supreme good
which turns out to be love by the way
which is why it keeps overflowing but
uh
the churches need to keep telling the
story the society needs it like mad
talk
addiction might be the way to name the
fundamental problem today spiritually
and psychologically and we got the
answer
the answer is grace the grace that
breaks you out of these addictive
patterns and it's right praise
it's you know paul tillich said that
tillich said all you need to know about
someone you can learn by asking one
question what do you worship that's
right i've always thought that's dead
right uh what is of highest value to you
once i know that i know everything about
you you just said about the the streams
flowing yeah i'll know everything i need
to know about you when you tell me
what's highest value to you is money or
even your family your culture your
society those are all good things but
they shouldn't be worshipped
and they're going to lead to addictive
patterns yeah and you can see if you
want to know where our society is you're
also you can also look at what are the
things that we're encouraged to worship
and what are the things that we're
allowed to worship right and so and it's
clear like there are certain values
which like you said like let's say for
example in the environmental question
there's it's a good question it's it has
it's a good
but it's when it becomes when we're
we're shown that this is what you need
to worship and any everything has to
submit to the worship of this whether it
be that or the idea of inclusivity there
are different values which have become
the supreme values and then all other
values have to kind of fit under them
but if it's not the right value if it's
not love right if it's not the infinite
uh source of the world then it's an idol
and it will have it'll have bad fruits
down the road at some point it's the
oldest story in the world and it's still
the best story and the one that we need
to keep telling and our job is not to
make the culture like us our job is to
proclaim this story
um because it's the story of of christ i
mean aquinas says if you want to be
happy
love what christ loved on the cross and
despise what he despised on the cross
it's a very cool little formula and what
he despised on the cross wealth pleasure
honor power you know to look at the
crucified jesus and say how much wealth
did he have how much pleasure is he
having how much power does he have how
much honor as they as they spit at him
and they mock him it's like he's taking
all the worldly values and he's
crucified to the world
what does he love on the cross but the
will of his father which allows grace
now to pour into the whole world and so
you want to be happy
thomas says and that's why he thought
the cross was where the beatitudes
appeared so the beatitudes are they're
moral guides in a way but they're
christological descriptions you know the
poor in spirit and so on and and those
who have eschewed wealth um
look at the cross and so we need to do
what paul did
you know i hold up christ and him
crucified we do this we have to do the
same thing because the culture needs
christ as much as it's ever needed
christ it seems to me yeah and there's
something and there's a mystery in that
which is
this is something people struggle to
understand in terms of christian
asceticism or the christian desire to
eschew the the desires of the world or
the the pleasures of the world is that
as you do that you actually discover the
ground of those pleasures as well right
you discover the reason why they exist
in the first place
and then they become rightly ordered in
your life and also in the society if
you're able to actually sacrifice them
to the highest good
do you know that it's from chesterton
because he he early in his life was kind
of agnostic and
and he said when i was convinced that
only the goods the world would make me
happy i was so unhappy
but once i became a christian i realized
oh they're not meant to make me happy
then i really started enjoying them
that's exactly the point you're making
so chesterton drinking and eating and
you know he loved life and full of humor
and all that
great great what liberates you for that
is precisely a liberation from
those things as objects of worship once
i'm free of that i can really enjoy them
as they're meant to be enjoyed but when
i start worshiping them they become a
source of torture and everyone knows
that right that
the thing i worship
it tortures me because it's never going
to make me happy and it keeps drawing me
obsessively to itself
um
and the church is that's our job is to
keep announcing it and what you do i
think artists do it by showing these
great images you know that embody these
spiritual truths
um
but we got to pick up our game i think
the culture's a problem for sure but we
got to pick up our game yeah you know
i think the young it's like i look at
the people that follow what i'm doing
you know and it's not it's not a massive
amount of people but let's say
there's a certain amount but they're
mostly young
yeah they're mostly like
20 to 30 35 and so what it feels like is
that it is also seed being planted and
that
even like let's say 10 years ago when i
started icon carving i was working with
an architect named andrew gould and we
realized that even in america the
orthodox church didn't have a culture of
beauty
and so we set out we started a journal
and we started writing articles and
putting out beautiful images and now 10
years later
we can see the seminarians that were
there 10 years ago
now they're the priests and we can feel
the changing culture and i think the
same with you i look around what you're
doing and i see the same thing a bunch
of young men like in their 20s who have
this energy and so
and so it seems like there's no other
because the other stuff is gonna die
it's already dying this kind of lame
christianity this materialist
christianity this kind of
ex supercritical christianity which
leads to atheists becoming you know
heads of theology departments and all
this kind of nonsense it's just going to
vanish it's it's and so what's going to
be left are those that have this cosmic
understanding and are able to
participate in it absolutely and the
self-loathing of christians is always a
source of frustration to me did you
notice it was a couple weeks ago when um
harvard university chose as like head of
chaplains a guy who's an atheist well i
i wrote this article about it just and
my my point was
not so it wasn't against him i'm sure
he's a nice guy i'm nothing against him
but i said it's the self-loathing of of
the christians at harvard who have such
a low regard for their own thing that
they'd say oh yeah i'm fine an atheist
someone who denies the existence of god
can represent
the chaplains you know i i mean it's
like you've just surrendered to the
priests of baal and i mean i'm
individually the priest of baal might
have been lovely people i'm saying if if
elijah just said well you know yeah
they're great you know sure let's have
one of them in charge of the temple and
come on i mean why why have we
surrendered we've got the words of of
eternal life and it's not arrogant to
say that it's what all the great saints
knew and all their humility the great
saints knew that and so
i i hate the self-loathing of christians
i think yeah
and but there's an it there's really an
interesting there's a transformation
happening like i'm perceiving it in
secret you could say where
i had this crazy experience where i i
you know there are priests giving these
catechumenate classes online now because
they can't they couldn't meet during the
the kobe dance so one asked me if i
could come to this class who's given to
catechumen so with all these young
people these 20 year olds and one of the
guys expressed he said he said i'm not
sure i'm doing this for the right reason
and he he said because i feel like i'm
i'm here doing this because this is the
place to be
this is the coolest place like this is
the future and that it's like it's it's
like uh in these fantasy stories where
people are rediscovering this ancient
mystery that has been lost this is the
this is the edge that we have is that
people don't know about the entire
mystical tradition of the church they
don't know about the entire symbolic
tradition of the church they have this
silly superstitious
vision of what it is and very
superficial and so if it doesn't take a
lot to just poke at that and show them
this powerful mystery that is there
which is true and so you can actually
shock people into realizing what
religion is about because they think
it's nothing
and then they'll inhabit the moral space
much more efficaciously and much more
powerfully when it's fed by these
mystical sources but when you cut off
the mystical sources as superstitious
and then he said we're going to just
hang on to these great social justice
principles well then we become an echo
of the culture then who cares and if our
buildings look like they could be
banks or they could be
you know a purely secular spaces who's
going to be interested but when you've
got
a shark cathedral that looks like it's
landed from another world which indeed
it has right
um i love the fact that uh kenneth clark
one of my great heroes did civilization
many years ago you know the great art
historian and he he was at chart and he
said
keep in mind this was all painted and
vivid colors he said how much even more
fiercely tibent tibetan it would have
looked and it's always struck me that i
imagine chart not just sort of blank but
alive with color
it landed from another world yeah
and you're meant to be drawn into this
this world transforming vision of
everything if our churches and our our
behavior and our self-understanding is
just a vague echo of the culture
everyone's gonna get bored and of course
young people will stay away in droves
but they will be attracted i'm glad you
mentioned the word on fire gang because
i do have all these extraordinary young
people super smart very artistic um
hyper motivated they won't be turned
down i i called it beige catholicism
years ago when i first got back from my
doctoral studies i began writing and i
wrote a little essay about beige
catholicism we've
allowed our colors to bleed into this
bland beige well no one's going to be
interested
i wanted something fiercely tibetan
about our catholicism i want it to be
edgy and colorful and challenging um
we're lucky in montreal we have have you
been to notre dame basilica in montreal
yeah sure as
they it's like it's as if you feel that
you are in shock in the middle ages they
have the ceilings painted with gold
stars and you know all the pillars are
are ornamented and everything and you
think like wow i can project this into
space and know what it would have been
like to stand in these medieval
cathedrals you know we forgot though
this is a story i've told before i don't
know if i did it with with peterson but
uh with a classmate of mine many many
years ago i was a student in paris and i
took him down to chard to show him and
we went all through charlotte and i
explained everything to him and and then
he said um yeah it's great it's just so
liturgically off
and
because he had been trained the way i
was with you know the liturgy should be
in a circle and we all see each other
and it's all leveled out and adm style
but like here's this chart which as you
say goes right back to the temple uh
it's like the most liturgically correct
place i can imagine
but the way we were trained that that
was the right response it was yeah it's
too bad you know it's old it's
old-fashioned it's not liturgically
correct
that means something's gone wrong with
the human spirit
um so we are we're recovering it there
is better church architecture today
within catholicism there's a better
sense of the cosmic point of the liturgy
the temple all that yeah i think so i
i've seen
several i mean there are several
liturgical movements that are kind of
popping up and also there's something in
the thinning which will produce that
same thing because
as the social justice
type person that only wants the moral
aspect of christianity finally realizes
that there's no reason to go to church
anymore it's getting it's kind then the
people that are left are going to be the
people that love
the tradition that love the you know to
be connected to what our ancestors kind
of gave us to have this this really
grounded sense that we are in a this
this story like we're participating in
the story you know that story in
scripture this is still your story yeah
and you're in it and all of this this
this whole you know we've been doing a
series in uh on my channel called
universal history where we're going back
into all the legends all the things that
the historians threw out all of it we're
just saying we're gonna re-explore this
you know even the things that they told
us was completely stupid like professor
john and all of these traditions no
we're gonna we're gonna explore it and
look at what it means and what it's
helped what it helps us understand about
you know what it means to be a society
what it means to worship and how this
all kind of comes together
if you want to
this ethical thing in mind i want to see
what you think as i think about this
go back to the civil rights movement 50s
and 60s right in our country that were
led by for the most part very religious
people so king the most obvious example
but the many others
religious people that led this movement
and you read the sermons of martin
luther king i mean he's grounded in in
the hebrew prophets he's grounded in the
great biblical tradition he's grounded
in jesus etc
and so his social justice activism
had a deeply i'd say mystical and
spiritual source
the fact that today
this sort of revived social justice
movement is not being led by religious
people in fact there's a great hostility
to religion
i think has given this present moment a
much darker
hue it's it's a much it's a much less
edifying spectacle because the
leadership is not grounded in the
mystical and the biblical and the
prophetic and so it will turn in short
order into simply a us against them
deeply violent or king i mean look at
king's language it's
judged not by the color of the skin but
the content of their character and he
said i want
i want to draw
white people into the beautiful
community i don't want to expel them
from it etc but well that's coming up
out of a isaiah sort of vision of things
the loss of the mystical the prophetic
and the biblical
we can see it today can't we that's my
theory and in the social justice
movement it has
it's it's a much
it's a much more dire prospect today
than it was 50 years ago and it looks it
it like you said it's very dark because
what it ends up looking like and it it's
sad because i don't think people are
going to be able to perceive it until
it's too late is that it it ends up
looking more like a pogrom or a mob like
a mob justice thing you know
it's it's not yet bloody or not very
much it's still in words and in and in
you know online and everything but that
pattern you know of finding the victim
you know destroying their life and
getting rid of them is something which
that definite will inevitably start to
bleed out into into culture i mean
people do lose their jobs and there's
all of this happening so we can see that
the very
the very pattern of desiring justice and
desiring supposedly out of love and
compassion is turning into
the very thing that they hate
absolutely the gerardian dynamics you're
relating to there the scapegoating stuff
is for sure and i always go back to you
know isaiah chapter 2 this this
beautiful image again it's evocative of
the temple and of eden and everything
else mount sinai
is the tribes of the lord go up the
sacred mountain well they go up the
sacred mountain because the temple is
there at the top of it and it's all the
tribes not just of israel but then all
the tribes of the world
that's the vision but what unites them
it's not a some social justice uh
conviction it's not some kantian ethical
imperative it's the worship of the true
god they come up the mountain together
to worship the true god that's what
draws us together
without right worship
attempts at togetherness are going to
fail and they're going to fall into
something like dissension and
scapegoating and us against them
so again that's the answer is what's on
top of the sacred mountain is the place
of right worship that's the only force
that we see in revelation too it says
that jerusalem gathers the glories of
all the people into it as the as the
lamb is at the center of this whole
pattern absolutely you know that's why i
remember in our conversation with jordan
peterson and he was
i think john was as well talking about
the kind of psychedelic drug stuff and
was that influencing the author of
revelation and i mean again who knows
what the author of revelation was taking
i don't know but you and i both said
some version of no no that stuff is
grounded in ezekiel and in daniel and
you know it
you don't need in other words
psychedelic drugs to come up with those
images they're they're from the literary
and spiritual tradition of of the old
testament um yeah and by the way thank
you it was nice to have another
christian with me because i've been
having this psychedelic discussion with
so many people it's like it's in the
culture so it was nice to have you there
to kind of maybe a little push back
against that that that
that tendency in culture i don't think
it's i don't think it's leading us in
the right direction and as you said i
mean i've never taken psychedelics but
it's like i know the iconographical and
typological language of scripture and so
when i see revelation and i've read
daniel and ezekiel and i've seen the
frescoes and this whole the the space of
the church and the way it's laid out in
terms of iconography it all makes sense
to me it doesn't absolutely
can i ask you a question you know i my
academic area of specialization is
aquinas
and
people i say aquinas and augusta and
aquinas aristotle and so on but i've
always been struck by how eastern thomas
is because you've got pseudo-dionysius
the ariappa guide is a huge influence on
him but also chris system is a huge
influence gregory of nis is a huge
influence
john of damascus he quotes he calls him
dominos he quotes him all the time
um
gregory i mentioned gregory vanessa uh
who's your go-to guy among the eastern
figures like of those i mentioned do you
have someone that really has anchored
things for you well for me it
for me it's really uh let's say in terms
of symbolism it's saying gregor of nissa
and in terms of in terms of uh let's say
the full vision it's saying maximus the
confessor maximus yeah
his v his understanding that his theory
of the logoe you know and how it all
comes together and unites which is
grounded in dionysus of course to me is
not only what grounds me but i i feel
like it's something that i can use
to reground christianity for the
contemporary world because because it
has something to do with meaning
and the capacity for man as the locus of
meaning all of this makes so much sense
and can be explained to people today so
he's really he's definitely the person i
go to yeah you know when i was a
doctoral student in paris i went to my
first seminar with michelle corban who's
still alive he's a jesuit a priest there
and he turned out to be my my doctoral
director i didn't know that at the time
but he introduced himself to us all and
he said um
i now either say
i'm now i'm i'm 50.
he said when i was a young man i read
hey girl i read heidegger i read uh you
know everyone that we were supposed to
read and he said now that i'm 50 i find
i jolie gregoire denise now i read
gregory nissa and it was maybe the first
time i'd really heard
gregory of nissa i was about 28 at the
time i guess um but i always think of
corban when you mention gregor of nissa
that he he just found him to be such a
go-to guy at that point in his life
and corbin was in fact very influenced
by the greek fathers and that sort of
got me into that world a bit when i was
doing my doctoral work yeah the the the
life of moses you know i've got some
kind of deep analyses of the life of
moses and
that
that structure the way the whole
narrative like the the way that he sets
everything up and he the way he he he
creates this pattern of the mountain and
then opposes different things is
it's the key i've done a talk where i
draw the mountain and
put up all the elements and they show
icons
so people can see that the pattern that
sangrego is sangro is calling to is the
the underlying pattern of the
architecture of the church and of all
the icons it really is he really his
vision was so
was so powerful i mean it's so short the
text is so short you have to be careful
not to miss things you know because
they're all so condensed together
yeah yeah and santa from the syrian too
is my
friend the hymns on paradise i think are
really useful for people today like he
does typological reading like nobody
does because he does it in a poem
where he moves from the old testament to
the new testament and he gives us the
keys basically as he's doing it it's
very powerful how about gregory palomas
do you follow him a lot it's just too
hard to read for me yeah i find it so
difficult to read and so i leave that to
others he's often called the aquinas of
the east you know he has that kind of
scholastic and i i taught at one point
in our program i had to teach
that era and so i read some of the texts
of gregory and um
the whole thing about the
transfiguration and the energies versus
the essence all that business um
anyway it's interesting for the thomas
to engage him
well definitely
i how can i say this i can see
i can understand basically the essence
energy distinction and i can understand
that
with that distinction it what it gives
it gives a possibility
a clear possibility of the man which god
can be completely imminent now you know
and also at the same time absolutely
transcendent and how there's no
confusion in that but beyond that i
struggled with a lot of the really
pointed the distinction people make and
i just leave that to the theologians at
some point
you know i think with with
pseudo-dionysius uh the very young
aquinas goes with albert the great
to cologne as like his uh assistant and
albert the great we know was teaching
the divine names of the pseudo-dionysius
and the young aquinas we actually have a
manuscript in his young hand a little
bit shaky and unsure where he's copying
out albert's lectures so the very young
aquinas took in dionysius in a deep way
and it's all through his theology all
through it so it's not just some kind of
rationalistic aristotelian uh
a product it's deeply influenced by the
east and all the mysticism but it's it's
just it's the same with origen and many
of the fathers what happens is that
people read back into
the influences then they read back the
younger developments yeah so people will
view you know like late thomism and then
they'll put that back into saint thomas
and the same thing with origin and a lot
of the a lot of these so it's it's it
becomes a lot of
i i really try to stay away from that as
much as possible i'm i'm
luckily i'm an artist and i can just
show images and so i never get into i
rarely get into theological arguments
because i'm just i'm just showing you
these images of of how these patterns
are there and typological just you know
relationships between the old and the
new it's it's not as it's not as
frustrating let's say for me i love it
that way
well bishop aaron i i would say i think
we we've gone quite a bit i would say
thank you for for your time thank you
for your your attention and thanks for
engaging jordan i
not that many christians at the outset
were willing to really kind of jump in
and try to
grab you know
to kind of grasp what he was saying to
to be able to criticize him for the
things that he's going nuts about but
then also really see the how it's
pulling in people towards the church and
we've seen it and so thank you for that
that uh courage let's call it i'll just
say one quick thing about that um a
couple years ago now i was chair of the
bishops committee on evangelization i
had to give a talk on uh what they call
the nuns right the n-o-n-e-s all the
young people leaving so i gave all the
stats and said here's i think why
they're leaving and then i said here are
some signs of hope and i went through a
number of things and my last one was
i said the jordan peterson phenomenon
and i said look i'm not saying i'm
endorsing here by everything he's ever
said i don't even know if he believes in
god this was a couple years ago you know
i said but
he's this smart guy
in a non-flashy way talking about the
bible
to armies of young people in person and
and even bigger armies online and i said
i think
yeah i said i think that's hopeful for
us well i think a lot of the business
took it in for the bishops were fine but
catholic social media afterwards i mean
blows up because again everything's got
to be read politically and so jordan
peterson he's not totally on board with
all the identity politics stuff so he's
a bad guy bishop baron is recommending
this bad guy and i'm like
no no bracket all that i don't care
about all that forget all that i'm just
saying smart guy talking the bible is
turning on these young people that's a
sign of hope yeah and i still think
that's true and and like you said even
at the outset even
helping people to see the wisdom part of
it or see yeah how it
how it represents psychological patterns
which is something the father's
completely agreed with you know and so
it's it's it's bringing people
it's making people want to read
scripture it's like yeah absolutely
that's wonderful so absolutely yeah so i
still you know hold to that and um we'll
see what happens next yes exactly and so
thank you and so i'm looking forward to
everybody to see you know go in in the
comments you know to to to to ask
questions and everything and so maybe
one day we'll have a shaver and on again
if he's interested but thank you for
your time
i'd love that thanks jonathan